I found the line from episode 3 of The
Last of Us so here's my attempts at
Bill's rabbit dinner
I may have started watching The Last of
Us for Pedro Pascal's daddy energy but
it was at Bill and Frank's episode that
I became infected with a deep love for
the series first I see the rabbit legs
on both sides in the pan and then finish
it off in the oven
then I cut some shallots and cooked them
in the same pan as the rabbit using some
bourbon to deglaze the pan
I then added the red wine butter and let
it simmer to reduce into a sauce the
wine that Frank was impressed that bill
knew to pair with rabbit was a
Beaujolais which is actually a cheap
French wine and pretty easy to find at
your local store I made sure not to use
any infected cordyceps flour in this
recipe but I did serve some regular
mushrooms on the side so I should be
safe from